that the floodgates may open have they
yeah i mean i was fortunate today to be
fair by the way i was thinking um to
always try to console myself when in a
bad situation and i realized after round
three that actually i had
very difficult pairing at the start so i
played two two leaders i mean i honestly
don't consider prague to be
superior to the field um but
he proves me wrong so
yeah i i played basically the first two
you know guys who are at the top in the
first two rounds and then alleria was
also very strong so it's not surprising
i had little points after that i think
um so yeah now um levon that didn't seem
to be in good shape the game before this
one the second game
was very greasy i played very poorly at
some point as well i had two options one
was good one was bad i didn't yeah and i
obviously picked the wrong one and then
i'm here overpressed and missed this
very nice cute tactic but still i was
very lucky you got a lucky river as we
say in poker uh yeah i mean you know
whatever sports you name it people
always get lucky sometimes and i just
got lucky today i think he was not not
at his best
uh regardless
does it even out after a seven seven
rounds here with the luck that you're
receiving i mean sometimes you play
players who are doing
over what they should then sometimes you
have players who is not quite playing up
to their level
well in general how i consider top chess
is basically so you have to be like
really talented and like work really
really hard and do everything you can
but the moment you actually
play and of course you have to give your
best and stuff but there is the outcome
is basically decided by luck i mean
magnus force is better than the rest so
um
he is on average scoring better but
otherwise like when i play other peers i
feel we've already done everything and
now it's just acquaint us of course it's
not just the coin toss like if i do coin
toss with the random guy i'm going to
beat him
but
if you do everything right and you are a
professional chess player
the result will be decided will be
basically a coin toss that's how i see
it
i have to look at your t-shirt because
we were talking about finding a new
t-shirt yesterday and now it's the girls
just want to have fun and obviously play
chess yeah i
mean uh
it was the idea of um that's just 24
you know they they think they're funny
so they heard the interview and they
brought this t-shirt and they said you
have to play in it tomorrow and i was
like sure i mean um but you know to be
honest it's a way of promoting human
chess um
so that i referred to it is kind of
funny though you weren't sitting in that
playing hall uh full filled with the old
man and uh
you know there's a guy with a t-shirt
girls just want to have fun play chess
but yeah
i i've even heard that the feedback is
maybe intending to do not just a year of
women in chess but like four years of
women in chess so that's a big um
a big thing right now uh in all fields i
think but um
to empower women and so on but
especially just in particular as well
and uh it's it's also a shortcut to grow
to growing the chess audience because um
you know there's like i don't know five
percent of women uh in chess and if you
make it 50 50
you basically double your audience
pretty much so
that that's also uh and by audience i
mean it's just audience so like the
people playing chess so
yeah i think not a bad t-shirt to wear
thank you honest and good luck tomorrow
thank you